STRANGE BRUINS.
A LOT GOING ON INTHE BOARD.
LINE.
WILL MILLER HALL.
HALL WITH THAT GREAT SPEED.
HAD HIS CAREER YEAR WHEN FOR
JOHANSEN.
ALEX JOHANSEN AGAIN. GREAT SAVE
CHARLIE McAVOY A CREATIVE MOVE,
TESTININ GOING TO
LAND.
IT'S TOMASINO.
GOT BY HIM.
TOMASINO PRESSURES THE PUCK
AREA. JUST FINDING THE NEXT
THREAT.
>> Willy: THE BOARDS, GETTING
CONTROL, RECOGNIZING THAT ROMAN
JOSI WASASWATCH BURIES A
POWER PLAY GOAL.
>> Chris: AND THIS IS A STORY
TURNOVERAN OPTION DOWN THE
ROAD IF DRAFT WITH ALL OF THOSE
GUYS FROM NET, DIES
OUT THERE.
BACK THEY COME.
SHOT RICOCHETED.
BOUNCING HURRY.
TOLVANEN!
STOPPED! POWER PLAY
FOR THE SECONDNDTHE LINE.
SLOWED DOWN, BOROROHAULA RESCUE
THE PLAY.
>> Chris: THE "PREDS" THIRD.
NASHVILLE DOWN A PAIR.
FORSBERG ONE OF THE THE MO
THE BRUINS FINALLY OPINION
WELL, THEY MIGHT THROW THEM E O
THEN AS SOON AS YOU BREEZE
PAST, YOU GET THAT STICK BACK
OUT HERE.
>> EXCELLENT PENALTY KILL.
10th IN THE LEAGUE. IT BACK OUT
EKHOLM LOOKS ONE WAY, THIS IS T
HOUSE.
ELECTION TRY IT, AND TRIED
THAT PLAY, AND THAT'S BEEN
QUITE HONESTLY THE BEST
OPPORTUNITIES HIGH.
EKHOLM TO JOSI A SECOND NDS.
TIPPED!
JUST WIDE.
JOHANSEN WILL TRY TO REDIRECT.
TOMASINO ALL